the rich are not paying their fair share
in any nation you should raise taxes on
the very rich as a rich person I pay 28%
tax what I want to ask you is why am I
not paying 50 tax day is fast
approaching which means increasing
anxiety for most of us among the bottom
99% of filers and bitching and moaning
among billionaires and millionaires
about how they're not forced to pay
enough in taxes as the most legendary
investor of the past 50 years you'd
expect Warren Buffett to understand a
balance sheet as a former US senator and
presidential candidate you'd expect
Secretary of State Clinton to know
something about federal spending problem
and as the author behind Maximum
Overdrive
a 1986 film about big rig trucks and
other machines terrorizing patrons at a
rest stop it expects Stephen King to
what these well-heeled plutocrats have
all wrong is this the US doesn't have a
revenue problem or a tax rate problem
we've got a spending problem since 1950
top marginal rates have varied from the
90% range to the high 20% range but the
government's take from all sources has
remained constant at around 18% of gross
domestic product and government spending
over that same time period has averaged
around 20% of GDP that's your deficit
right there folks
all the carping about the rich getting
off easy may help you win elections and
sleep soundly at night even after
reading a Stephen King novel I'm gonna
scare the hell out of you but it's not
gonna help the federal balance sheet one
penny
but if Buffett Clinton and King do want
to pay more they can lead by example and
head over to the Treasury Department's
website and make a voluntary
contribution to retire the federal debt
held by the public to date the feds have
collected over a hundred and twenty four
thousand extra dollars in 2011 which
means there's just about eight point
nine nine trillion dollars to go
for raisin TV I'm Nick Gillespie